abone ol
bu tarafa
Evet önce sana sonra diğer bütün
katılımcılara Merhaba diyorum hepiniz
hoşgeldiniz Biz Hayaller gerçekleştirmek
içindir diyerek çıktığım Hayat
yolculuğunda birkaç küçük hikaye
paylaşacağım bu akşam sizinle bilim
döndüğünce
heyecanlıyım Çünkü
şühü Hayaller başla beni çok etkiledi
kadınlar ve Hayaller daha da etkiledi bi
Peki ben Hayaller yolculuğuma nasıl
başladım
Her şey çocuklukta başlıyor orası net
Çocukken de çok hayal kuran bir çocuktum
belki isminde etkisi vardır Bilmiyorum
Serap olmandan dolayı
bu ama çocukluk hayallerimi çok
destekleyen ve anlayan beni besleyen Bir
ailem vardı
Bir öğretmen mutfağından kitabımızda da
aslında biraz bunları da değildi Man bu
Buraya küçük tüyolar vermeye çalışırken
hayalleride soktum kitabın arasına Çünkü
gerçekten çocukluk hayalleri çok
kıymetli
çocuklarınızın hayallerini sımsıkı
sarılın derim ben onlar hayal kurarken
Lütfen onları destekleyin ne kadar da
saçma Hayal vermiş hiç böyle hayal olur
mu demeyin Çünkü o çocuk bir gün sizin
saçma diye düşündüğünüz hayatta da böyle
bir şey olmaz diye yorumladı ımız bir
şey gerçekleştirirse çok utana
bilirsiniz O yüzden ben çocukluk
hayallerine sahip çıktım çocuk kendi
Hayal kurarken Ben hayalime böyle
kokular ekledim mis gibi kurabiye kokusu
geliyor Keşke annemin yanında olsam
dedim okuldayken arkadaşlar Oo Serap
yine hayallerin diye bana tepki
veriyorlardı aslında burada arkadaşların
da var westlake arkadaşlarında hala o
tepkiyi devam ediyor bu o ellerini
kurdukça o Hayır Serap Senin hayallerin
Ama iyi ki öyle oldular çocukken
kurduğum tüm hayallerine sahip çıktım
mesaj Şu anda bir öğretmenim Belki o
yüzden çocuklarda çok daha iyi anlıyorum
çocuklarla birlikte otururken en çok
şöyle yapıyoruz iç bir oyuncak yok sınıf
bomboş diye düşünün beraber oturmuşuz
Çocuklar şimdi bir orman dayız Biz kamp
kurmaya gittik
öğretmenim ateşte Olsun mu olsun
öğretmenim yanımda sırt çantalarımızı
alalım alalım başka ne olun yiyecekte
alalım aç kalmayalım sonra bir baktık
gibi sadece beş dakika beş dakika içinde
o çocukların dünyaları bambaşka
olabiliyor
çok mutlu oluyorlar
özgüvenleri gelişiyor onların
hayallerini dinleyen birisi var o yüzden
aramızda anne babalar var mutlaka sizden
küçük bir ricam lütfen çocuklarımızın
hayallerine saygı duyalım ve onlara
sahip çıkalım Tamam hiç çocuklukta böyle
e Çok da keyifli
Benim hayallerim kokusu var Evet biraz
önce de söyledim rengi var bütün
duygularımla hissederim Hayal kurduğunda
O yüzden de gerçekleştirme hızı çok
yüksek oldu çocukken bunu bilmiyordum
sonra okudum araştırdım Evet gerçekten
de Hayallerim frekansları çok yüksekmiş
yani Hayal kurarken dikkat etmek
gerekiyor güzel hayaller kurmak ve
gerçekleştirmek için başarmak için
hayaller kurmak kendiniz için insanlık
için ayarlar kurmak doğru ve güzel
hayaller bu dünyayı çok fayda getirecek
bunu da inanıyorum ve Bu sadece hayaller
mi kuruyoruz sadece hayaller kurmuyoruz
önce onu başarmış hız gibi hayal
ediyoruz ya işte onu hayal ettik Sonra
sabırlı bekliyoruz
çalışıyoruz ve çabalıyoruz şu anda
burada bir hayalin gerçekleştiği hep
beraber şahit oluyoruz Çünkü ben bu
hayali kurmuştum nasıl bir gün dedim
herkese hayallerimi anlatacağım bu ebede
kalabalık görünüyor Bence bu hayali
gerçekleştirmek için yeterli bir sayı
var benim için herkesi anlamında O
yüzden şu an gerçekleştirilmiş bir
hayali şahitlik ediyorsunuz
siz Peki Serap çocukken Hayaller kurduğu
çok güzel ilkokul döneminde
kıymetli öğretmenlerimiz saygıyla
anıyorum resim yapmayı çok sevdim ve
dedim ki bir isim öğretmen olmalıyım
resim öğretmeni hayaliyle yanıp
tutuşuyorum
sonra ortaokul döneminde hayatında çok
kıymetli bir müzik öğretmeni girdi benim
müziğe aşık etti o kadar çok sevdim ki
daha ortaokul yaşlarında şarkılar ve
söylemeye başladım şiirleri şarkıları
dönüştürüyorum notalar müzikler harika
Babama dedim ki ben müzik öğretmeni
olmaya karar verdim E tabi o zaman
şartları biraz daha farklı yok dedi ben
seni Konservatuarı gönderemem Eyvah
hayal kırıklığı hem de Serap'ın
Tamam o şimdi biraz Dursun
yıllar geçti lise dönme geldim lise
döneminde şiirleri çok sevdim edebiyatı
aşık oldum yazmayı çok sevdim hikayeler
yazdığım kompozisyonlar yazdım verilerim
oldu iyice büyüdü hayalim dedim ki ben
edebiyat öğretmeni olmalıyım ise
bitişigi hiçbir şey olmadı yani daha
doğrusu hayallerini kurdukları mı
olamadım ama İçimdeki Çocuk çocukları
çok sevdi ve bir Anaokulu öğretmen
olmaya karar verdim Okul öncesi eğitim
dönüm üniversitedeki döneminde
bitirirken dedim ki evet sarapsan müzik
öğretmeni olmak istiyorum olmadı ve
Resim öğretmeni olmak istiyordun olmadı
edebiyat öğretmeni olmak istiyordun
olmadı ama hayallerime devam ettim bu
hayal kurmaya devam ettiğiniz sürece
Hayaller sizi bırakmıyor lütfen içinize
dönmeyi hayallerinizi sahip çıkmayı asla
unutmayın Ben tüm hayalleri kurarken
tepkiler de aldım Saçmalama Serap neler
kuruyorsun öyle hayal çocuk işidir Bu da
çok önemli bir nokta Hayaller çocuk işi
değildir
Hayaller herkesin işidir O yüzden büyük
olun küçük olun Hiç fark etmez Hayal
kurmaya devam edin Hatta çocuklarınıza
örnek olun birlikte Hayal kurun birlikte
Hayal kurduğunuzda Onların ne kadar çok
çabaladık larında göreceksiniz Ben
sadece Anaokulu çocuklar için
önermiyorum bunu
ergenlik dönemi çocuklarımız için
gençlerimizin herkes için öneriyorum
hayal kurmanın yaşı yok Sizinle dalga
geçmeye çalışan etrafınızdaki Diğer
kişilere de lütfen hayallerinizi
vermeyin hayallerinizi sahip çıkıp Peki
üniversitede ve çok keyifli bir
üniversite dönemi geçirdim Evet tüm
mücadele derimizde kadın olmanın verdiği
mücadelelerle
azimle başarıyla okulunu bitirdim
sonrasında besleyin içinde çocuklarla en
çok resim yapmayı Sevdim yani resim
öğretmenliği Duygu mu doyasıya tatmin
ettim çocuklarla Şarkı Yaptım besteler
yaptım onlar için birlikte şarkılar
söyledim ve müzik öğretmenliği Duygu mu
bu tattım
sonrasında
geriye bir şey daha kaldı edebiyat
öğretmenliği ne büyük keyifti benim için
Çünkü bu mesleğimin ilk yılları
Ben sadece Öğretmenlik yapmak
istemiyorum heyecanlıyım yine Hayaller
böyle uçuşuyor dedim ki ben çok şiir
yazdım bu şiirleri mi toplamalıyım bir
kitap haline getirmeliyim
Hayır her bir şey olmaz şiir kitabı
satmıyor zaten Ne yapacaksın şiir kitabı
çıkartıp da satsın diye değil
bu geride benden Biz bir iz bırakmak
için şiir kitabı çıkarmak istedim
şeylerin hepsini de aradım topladım
Bugün bir arkadaşımla konuşuyorum
sevgililerin onu sevgilerimi
gönderiyorum buradan selam Hayallerin
çok güzel çok da güzel hayal kurduğun
ama gerçekleşmesi için bir adım daha var
Nedir o gerçek hayal kurun Nasıl yani
bir tarih koyalım bir hedef bir planlama
31mart 2007 tarihine o günü koyduk ve
ben canla başla Yayınevi arıyorum
şiir kitabı çıkartmak istiyorum Bana
yardımcı olurmusunuz ünlü müsünüz
ya Hayır değilim manken misiniz değilim
ünlü yakalamışsınız Hayır değil siyasi
içerikli mi şiir kitabınız Yok hayır
tamamen aşk kokuyor o zaman üzgünüz şiir
kitabını çıkartacağız büyük bir hayal
kırıklığı Hem de benim için Tabii ki
yarın bırakmadım bu hayalim madem ben
sadece bir iz bırakmak istiyorum
amacımız satış değil o zaman kendi
şartlarımıza bir matbaa ile anlaştım ve
özel bir sayıda şirket aldığımı çıkartıp
eşime dostuma arkadaşlarıma benden bir
anı bıraktım ve metha bu şekilde doğdun
İyi ki de doğdu bir kişiyi kitabımı
ortaya çıkartıp Çok da mutluyum
hayallerin ortaya çıkmış olmasından
dolayı ilham perileri devam ediyor
harika
Bu arada tabii ki yolculuğum beni
oğlumun da doğumuyla beraber
Çanakkale'ye yetirdi Çanakkale'de bu
taraftan İstanbul'dan ayrılmanın gruplu
bir diğer taraftan da Çanakkale'de yeni
bir hayat kurmanın heyecanı ve yine
Hayaller başladı yol aldım yol aldım
dedim ki ben Epeydir Tabii ki Mesleğimi
buraya geldiğimde burada 10. Senem ne
mutlu bana burada 10. sinir
gerçekleştirirken meslekte 22 yılımı
devrilmiş oluyorum Çok şükür
Dolayısıyla anne babalar için çok şey
birikti wendy ve dedim ki Çanakkale'deki
anne-babaları ulaşmak istiyorum onları
okul öncesi eğitimi okul öncesi eğitim
döneminde sahip çocukları varsa
rehberlik etmeyi nasıl başarabilirim
diye düşünürken kendi kendime gittim
aktüel dergisinin kapısını çaldım
kıymetli yazar aynı zamanda o zaman
derginin editörü olan Hasan Sami Bey
bini sevgiyle karşıladı yazılarımı
okuduğu ve hocam Tamamdır dedi çıkaralım
ve mı yoksa dergisinde köşe yazarı
yapmaya da bu şekilde başladım bir
hayalim daha gerçekleşmiş oldu peki ya
sonrası sonra yolum çabaçam da
devam etti çalışan benim için çok
kıymetli bir yer burada bir gün Profesör
Doktor Ebru Aktan Acar'ın da o Çaçan
hayalini düşünü anlatıyor musun Çok
isterim sizi dinlemesini bu çok büyük
bir hayal kurduk uçağımı yarattı ve O
hayal için dediği gibi şarkı yapar mısın
Ne büyük Şeref çamaşır için Oradaki
çocuklar için bir şarkı besteledim adını
Bir düş koyduk ve müzikle ilgili
duygularımı da hayallerimde bu şekilde
gerçekleştirmeye devam ettim sonrasında
Ben Bir Öğretmenim mutfağından tohumları
bu şekilde Aslında biraz biraz atılmış
oldu aktüel yazıları ile beraber daha
çok anne babayı nasıl ulaşırım mı
hedefledim Sadece dergide kalmasını
istedim Çünkü birkaç sene yazdım dergide
bv1 öğretmeni mutfağından kitabın için
Çin 2020 yılında harekete geçtim Bu
sefer birini Yayınevi reddetmedi ne
büyük mutluluk
reddedilmeyen bir cevaptan sonra
sevgili Özgür Bey anda sevgiyle
selamlıyorum eğiten kitap için bütün
yazılarını bir araya getirip
çok küçük küçük tüyolar vermeye çalıştım
anne-babalara rehber olmaya çalıştım
onların çocuklarıyla güçlü Bağlar
kurmasına yardımcı olmaya çalıştım Her
şey çok yolunda gidiyor Çok güzel geri
bildirimler alıyorum o yüzden de hep
diyorum lütfen hayalinizi sıkı sıkı
sarılın ben birçok hayalimi burada daha
size anlatamayacağım ne kadar çok şey
var aslında birçok hayalini
gerçekleştirmiş bulunuyorum İyi ki de
hayal kurdum lütfen Sizlerde Hayal
kurmayı Çocuk saçı çocukça bir şeymiş
gibi düşünmeyin lütfen hayallerimizi
sımsıkı sarılın hele ki bu zamanda her
iki dünya böyleyken
diyeceksiniz ki yani Hayal kurmak ne
kadar yani Dünya nasıl bir faydası
olabilir dünyayı bilmiyorum ben kendi
adıma
insanlığa Küçücük de olsa biz katkı
sağlayabilecek hayaller kurdum a
inanıyorum çocuklara dokundurma
inanıyorum anne-babaları dokunabildiğin
ve inanıyorum bu Kalplere dokunabildiğin
ve inanıyorum O yüzden de benim
hayallerim çok kıymetli Sizler de
hayallerinize sahip çıkın derim Peki
nasıl devam edebilirim diye çok düşündüm
bu konuşmanız akabinde
anlatacak çok şey var hayallere dair
Umarım bu konuşmamdan sonra herkes biraz
cebine biraz da kalbine hayallerinizi
biriktirmiş olursunuz birazcık
düşünebiliriz eve gittiğimizde nasıl
Hayaller kurarsam gerçekleşmesine
yardımcı olurum değil küçücük bir sır
lütfen
hayallerinizi başarmakla ilgili
hayallerinizden bahsediyorum aramızda
gençler de var şu an üniversite
okuyanlar hedefleri büyük olanlar var
Hedef çok kıymetli bu ama başarmakla
ilgili hayalinizi lütfen başarana kadar
paylaşma indirim en büyük sır ve mucize
burada ben bu mucizeyi doyasıya o Umarım
Sizlerde mucizeleri hayallerinizi
mucizelerini doyasıya yaşarsınız Ben bu
konuşmayı hazırlarken
Meryem hocam İyi ki bu haberi bana
verdiğimde Madem hayaller var işin
içinde dedim O zaman bir şiirle
sohbetimizi sonlandırmak isterim küçük
bir dörtlük ama heyecanım Ama artık
almak istemediğim için
ben yazmayı tercih ettim yazarak daha
iyi anlatabilirim derdimi diye düşündüm
O yüzden lütfen
okuduğum için kusuruma bakmayın
bu yolunuzda hayallerden Çakıl Taşları
nız olsun her daim
hayallerinizden kendinize doğru giderken
yolunuzu kaybetmemek adına
ışıklarız olsun rengarenk
tutunun ve Uçan o renklerin peşinde
çocuk kahkahaları olsun hep İçinizde
duyun kendi çocukluğunuzun sesini her ne
olursa olsun
gerçekleştirmek üzere yola çıktığınız
bir hayaliniz olsun her daim yolda
yolculukta hayallerinizde bol olsun
çocuk da ısı Sevgilerimle şey
[Müzik]